are they watching okay we're here I
thought of what I meant to say the whole
world is watching and here are the
questions we're gonna ask Richard
painter do you think the ethical
degradation seen in this presidency will
be a permanent reality for the office
well it couldn't get worse but I sure
hope no this takes some digging out
after if we've survived this is a low
point he is combined all of the sins of
all the past presidents I don't even get
me started
I know that's why we got you here to get
your shirt congressman Schiff Dems get
majority in midterms what do you think
Congress should work on right away good
question well I think one of the biggest
challenges facing the country and it's
masked by this sugar high that we've had
from the stock market although that rise
so coming down from that high are
structural changes going on in the
economy the effect of automation is
going to be as disruptive to people in
retail as globalization was to
manufacturing and we need to prepare our
workforce for that we need to make sure
that young people can get the education
they need to be able to compete in a
newly automated work environment we need
to make sure the people in the middle of
their career who lose their job through
no fault of their own are able to get
another good job that pays just as well
and people at the end of their career
can retire in dignity here Democrats say
that all the time why don't they believe
you I'm talking about the coal miners
because that's what Hillary told the
coal miners and they just you know we
don't believe you we don't believe
you're gonna replace this job or come
and change my life in any way I need
that's the only job I can get and the
miner hit mine is here and I want to go
down in it and I feel like Democrats
have a real trouble making that
connection and convincing voters that
they can do things like that which is
that they have the right answer I think
you just don't sell thank you right well
first of all you can't give that talk
from Washington DC you need to be you
need to be in coal country and you need
to show people respect you need to start
out the conversation by saying I respect
what you've done for a living well your
parents did for a living how you put
bread on the table I can't say
that I'm gonna change the global economy
in energy and somebody who promises you
that I hope you know they're giving you
a line of bull but what I can't say is I
want to work with you to bring other
jobs here what do you want to see your
kids do and how do we make that happen
that's the kind of conversation I think
we need to have in coal country and
around the around the nation
it can't be talking down to people and
has to mean showing respect people in
coal come in in coal country we're told
if their kids just got an education
they'd be fine and they got an education
and there were no jobs for them we need
to be able to partner federal government
local government local business private
sector to help create jobs and the parts
of the country that have been left
behind this might be a dumb question
about the rest of thing but like if the
if the mueller report comes in any time
this year before the election right then
it'll be close to over once he gives his
report but if it happened after 2018 it
would be better for the Democrats right
because they then might be in power in
other words wouldn't it be better if the
mueller report came in 2019 when you
could impeach him if it comes in in 2018
when you can't impeach him because the
Republicans won't go along with that
doesn't it then just die in the woods
well so can't really stall with Gerson
what do you know he did Mike Pence is
way preferable to Donald definitely true
first of all he's not a Russian spy yes
yeah he's not as he's not wearing clown
makeup
you know he's knows how to govern yes
he's not a complete nut he's he's a wee
he's Bush
you won't take us to nuclear war right
[Laughter]
yes I'm so sorry look I think we
perceived the investigation as
expeditiously as we can and ironically
it's the Republicans who are slow
walking things now they want to
basically put the government on trial
this is what you do when you're a
defense attorney and the facts are
mounting against your client and he's
looking increasingly incriminated you
basically put the government on trial so
there are witnesses we want to bring in
they keep delaying their documents we
want to subpoena they keep delaying
they're the ones who are drawing this
out right now I can't tell you whether
it's better not for Bob Moe to finish
this year but I can't say this the most
important thing is that he'd be allowed
to do his job that for the record if
you're watching Bob Muller don't finish
this year wait till 2019 after the
Democrats maybe have at least one house
so this thing what a remarkable weave
right side of that he is actually but
he's an American yes and for most Bob
Miller is an American he's going to do
this job the responsible way publicans
the Trump is fighting against that's one
of the most amazing ironies of the whole
thing Coby he was a Republican Rod
Rosenstein well you can't even get along
with your own team well but Jimmy swung
the election to him that's what Nate
Silver thinks was the turning point and
particularly absurd for Trump to be now
claiming the FBI were trying to destroy
him when they were in fact helping him
the majority of America agrees with you
I'm sure because the majority of America
sees something totally different than
this 39-41 whatever purse image that
President Trump has but you have to
remember one of the reasons why we're in
the situation now is because things were
not played out the way they were
supposed to play out and they have to
play out the right way so you cannot say
well it was done this way it has to play
out the right way because it's too much
you're covered up too much
shifting shifted and everything every
for instance you know just with this
memo situation the Democrats had
something that gave from what
hearing from my sources a rebuttal line
for line in my correct line for line
against Nunez and they even gave a
different time line but the president
again wants to keep his narrative and
show the people what he wants to show
versus what the other side's had other
side has that could actually be more
factual than what Nunez says in Nunez
was actually what did he he recused
himself how in the world could he even
presented he used to be close didn't you
this is that this is the president on
the Nunez memo I'm vindicated responds
I'm it's classified pretty good friends
with Devin right we used to get along
very well together same home state same
support and love they're not well the
Chairman got very close to the president
during the campaign he was part of the
transition team
he had a seat at the table that's a
heady thing right and then when he was
put in charge of an investigation he
still want to maintain the seat at the
table absolute power and do both
credibly and and the investigation is
what suffered a lot of relationships
were broken in Washington DIMMs and
Republicans were able to at least talk
work things out I mean I had a lot of
Republican sources and democratic
sources and I lost a lot what they
perceived to be is that I'm a liberal
but they perceive I don't tell my
politics that I've lost a lot of
Republican sources and Republican
friends through this year last two years
this noonas memo doesn't say anything of
that the FBI was doing this job of going
and you're getting surveillance and FISA
warrant on people are hanging around
with Russian agents what was this I
support right that's that is their job
what I'm trying to do is Alex Jones it
just create a haze of [ __ ]
so 70% of Republican voters think the
FBI is biased against Trump
this haze' [ __ ] work and everybody
who gets caught in the net that the mic
flynn's and so forth
Bannen now you know have to have to go
and seem mueller do they get a message
from Trump do you think saying don't
worry about it I'll pardon you the
biggest nerd I placed a shortening of
Joe Arpaio that case Joe Arpaio that
case whack and over yet
and the message he sent there was you
have my back I won't even wait until
you're sentenced to use a pardon when he
was asked about Flint he said well we'll
see about that in other words we'll see
what he has to say is he with me is
against me of course that is so
destructive of our system of justice but
then that's the point
yes it's especially horrendous with our
pile actually interviewed Arpaio went to
the prison where he made women who had
serious addiction problems go out on a
chain gang wearing t-shirts saying I was
a drug addict while members of the
public mock and jeer at them I mean this
is one of the most wicked people you can
conceive of and Trump championing him
reveals so much about Trump the only
sees know he's running for Senate right
yes he's 87 right so we have Chelsea
Manning this is the state of our
politics Manning dinner with some really
admirable things durable pirates
Bennett's career devastatingly destroys
Manning has aligned herself with Mike
chernevich and the alt-right where she
went no but I said about her party which
was she went to intelligence on those
piece was the state about politics
remember when I'm lost on the panel
thank you
[Applause]